Plot 4 comma negative
1, and select
the quadrant in
which the point lies.
So 4, the first
number in our ordered
pair, that's our x-coordinate.
That says how far to move in the
horizontal or the x-direction.
It's a positive 4.
So I'm going to
go 4 to the right.
And then the second
coordinate says,
what do we do in the
vertical direction
or in the y-direction?
It's a negative 1.
Since it's negative,
we're going to go down.
And it's a negative 1, so
we're going to go down 1.
So that right over there is
the point 4 comma negative 1.
So I've plotted
it, but now I have
to select which quadrant
the point lies in.
And this is just a
naming convention.
This is the first quadrant.
This is the second quadrant.
This is the third quadrant.
And this is the fourth quadrant.
So the point lies in the
fourth quadrant, quadrant IV.
And I guess you have to
know your Roman numerals
a little bit to know that's
representing quadrant IV.
Let's do a couple more of these.
Plot 8 comma negative
4, and select
the quadrant in
which the point lies.
Well, my x-coordinate
is 8 so I go 8
in the positive x-direction.
And then my y-coordinate is
negative 4, so I go 4 down.
And this is sitting,
again, in not the first,
not the second, not the third,
but the fourth quadrant,
in quadrant IV.
Let's do one more of these.
Hopefully we get a
different quadrant.
So we want to plot the
point negative 5 comma 5.
So now my x-coordinate
is negative.
It's negative 5.
So I'm going to move to the
left in the x-direction.
So I go to negative 5.
And my y-coordinate
is positive so I go up
5, so negative 5 comma 5.
And this is sitting not
in the first quadrant,
but the second quadrant.
And of course, this is
the third and the fourth.
So this is sitting in
the second quadrant.
Check answer, and
we got it right.